Il successo del nostro algoritmo VQE dipende molto
dallo stato e dal circuit
che scegliamo all'inizio.
Sono Victoria Lipinska e in questo video
esploreremo le opzioni
che abbiamo nel progettarli.
Diamo un'occhiata più da vicino
a tutti gli elementi
che abbiamo in ogni esecuzione della parte
quantistica del VQE.
Iniziamo con lo stato di riferimento,
a volte chiamato stato iniziale.
Facciamo passare lo stato di riferimento
attraverso un circuit parametrizzato chiamato
forma variazionale
con una scelta iniziale di parametri,
e misuriamo lo stato
nella base dell'Hamiltoniano
dopo averlo fatto passare attraverso il circuit
per ottenere il valore di aspettazione. Ora
percorreremo ciascuno di questi elementi,
iniziando con lo stato di riferimento.
Una scelta tipica per lo stato di
riferimento è lo stato zero.
Ovvero lo stato in cui un computer
quantistico è già inizializzato.
Per i problemi di chimica quantistica,
si può anche usare il cosiddetto
stato di Hartree-Fock,
che è il risultato del
metodo di Hartree-Fock.
In breve, la teoria di Hartree-Fock
offre un modo semplice per costruire
lo stato di riferimento approssimando
lo stato fondamentale di un sistema quantistico.
Trova una rotazione
nello spazio degli stati
che minimizza l'energia dello stato fondamentale.
Infine, lo stato di riferimento
può anche essere molto specifico per il problema,
e potresti voler scegliere
uno stato personalizzato.
Nel caso in cui sai quali proprietà
ha il tuo sistema, ad esempio le simmetrie
o un numero specifico di elettroni
nello stato, puoi usarlo
per avere una migliore convergenza dell'algoritmo
VQE.
Scegliere un buono stato di riferimento
è importante per la convergenza:
stati di riferimento vicini
allo stato fondamentale
possono far convergere il problema
molto più facilmente e velocemente.
Ugualmente importante
è la scelta dei valori iniziali dei parametri
che inseriamo nella forma variazionale.
Pertanto, a seconda dello stato di riferimento
e dei parametri iniziali,
potremmo convergere rapidamente, lentamente
o non convergere affatto.
Guardiamo questo grafico
e per scopi di visualizzazione,
immaginiamo che il nostro spazio di parametri
abbia un solo parametro.
Uno stato di riferimento molto buono
ti può permettere di iniziare molto vicino
allo stato fondamentale finale
e la convergenza sarà rapida.
D'altra parte, se parti molto lontano
dallo stato fondamentale qui,
stato di riferimento
a, dovrai attraversare un'alta barriera energetica
che porta a una convergenza molto lenta
o a nessuna convergenza.
Discuteremo questo in modo più approfondito
nel modulo di ottimizzazione classica
in questo corso.
Guardiamo ora il circuit parametrizzato
che agisce sullo stato di riferimento, alias
la forma variazionale.
Quando questo circuit, sai,
il U di theta agisce sul riferimento
stato,
produce quello che chiamiamo stato di prova
psi di theta o a volte ansatz.
È questo stato ansatz che viene
poi misurato in una base appropriata
per ottenere il valore di aspettazione
per l'energia.
Le forme variazionali
di cui stiamo discutendo qui
sono motivate dalla chimica.
Tuttavia, tieni presente
che esistono anche quelle ispirate
dall'apprendimento automatico quantistico
e ad altri algoritmi near-term
come gli algoritmi di ottimizzazione
approssimata quantistica.
Discutiamo
alcune scelte comuni per un ansatz chimico.
Unitary coupled cluster o UCC
è il metodo originariamente proposto
nella prima pubblicazione VQE,
ed è comunemente usato nei problemi di
chimica quantistica.
In genere,
quando parametrizziamo uno stato quantistico,
lavoriamo con un numero esponenziale
di parametri.
Tuttavia, per rendere efficienti
i circuit di preparazione,
abbiamo bisogno del numero polinomiale
di operazioni
e quindi di un numero polinomiale
di parametri.
UCC è un esempio di un modo per preparare
uno stato di prova con tale circuit
e deriva da un metodo coupled cluster,
che è lo standard di riferimento nella
chimica quantistica.
La scelta più comune è il unitary
coupled cluster
singles and doubles
ansatz o UCCSD in breve.
Poiché UCCSD è motivato dalla specifica
configurazione elettronica di un problema,
dobbiamo assicurarci di avere uno stato di riferimento
che rifletta correttamente il sistema.
Questo è lo stato di Hartree-Fock.
L'ansatz UCCSD di solito dà
una buona approssimazione dello stato fondamentale
perché cattura le eccitazioni elettroniche
singole e doppie in una data molecola.
Il numero di parametri in UCCSD scala
quadraticamente con il numero di
spin orbitali.
UCCSD può essere molto ben
adattato a un problema,
ma purtroppo la scalabilità quadratica
porta comunque a circuit molto profondi
che sono difficili per i computer
quantistici attuali.
Ecco perché i ricercatori IBM hanno proposto
un approccio più euristico,
dove si può adattare una forma variazionale
all'hardware sottostante
che risulta in un circuit
eseguibile in modo efficiente.
Cioè, gli stati di prova sono parametrizzati
da gate quantistici
e sono adattati
al dispositivo fisico disponibile.
Questo è un approccio molto euristico
che è compatibile con l'hardware.
Basandoci su questi esempi, diamo un'occhiata
allo spettro di possibilità
che abbiamo per esprimere
la nostra forma variazionale.
Molte di queste
sono già implementate in Qiskit
quindi ti incoraggio a provare tu stesso
quale sia la più adatta
al problema che stai cercando di risolvere.
Se guardiamo il grafico, da un lato
abbiamo le forme variazionali
molto euristiche.
Quando la specificità del problema è bassa, ma
sono progettate per essere implementate
sull'hardware reale.
Sono anche altamente espressive, nel senso
che si possono esprimere
molti stati quantistici con loro.
Tuttavia,
un problema che può verificarsi nella fase successiva
dell'ottimizzazione classica
è incontrare
il cosiddetto barren plateau,
di cui parleremo nel prossimo modulo.
D'altra parte,
abbiamo l'unitary coupled cluster altamente specifico per il problema
che funziona
eccellentemente nella chimica classica ma
è difficile da implementare sull'hardware
quantistico a causa delle grandi profondità del circuit.
In generale, i calcoli
possono avere più successo se riesci a,
prima di tutto scegliere uno stato di riferimento
e un insieme iniziale di parametri
che creano uno stato ansatz
vicino allo stato fondamentale.
E secondo, evitare parametri non necessari.
Questi introducono o
una maggiore profondità del circuit senza alcun vantaggio
oppure creano uno spazio dei parametri più grande
da ricercare, portando a plateau
nell'ottimizzazione classica.
Quali parametri siano necessari è una questione
specifica del problema
che richiede un'attenta riflessione.
Parliamo di dove si nasconde il nostro ospite d'onore,
l'Hamiltoniano, in tutto questo.
Come abbiamo appreso nella sezione precedente,
l'Hamiltoniano dopo la mappatura qubit
è rappresentato come una somma di
stringhe pesate di operatori di Pauli.
Alla fine, però,
vogliamo valutare il valore di aspettazione
del nostro Hamiltoniano sullo stato ansatz
prodotto dalla forma variazionale.
Fortunatamente, la meccanica
quantistica è piacevole e lineare
e questo è ciò che useremo
per ottenere il valore di aspettazione.
Ecco come funziona.
Sappiamo che l'Hamiltoniano è una somma
pesata di Pauli
per la linearità
il valore di aspettazione della somma
è uguale alla somma dei valori di aspettazione
di ogni stringa di Pauli.
Bene, questo è ottimo perché come sai già,
misurare nella base di Pauli
è semplice come una rotazione
della base di misura standard.
Invece di misurare il valore di aspettazione
su questo enorme Hamiltoniano rappresentato
come una somma, valutiamo prima i valori di aspettazione
dei singoli termini
e sommiamo alla fine
con i pesi corrispondenti.
Ecco perché in molte risorse
vedrai solo rotazioni su singolo qubit
dopo l'ansatz.
Questo è ciò che implementa l'Hamiltoniano
in ogni esecuzione del circuit.
Nel prossimo video,
esploreremo cosa accade
durante il passo di ottimizzazione classica.
Ci vediamo lì.